we used to wrestle against this um you
know like those those like neighborhood
Legend guys were like oh man we got to
go up against it there was this black
dude named Mike Jones at Westminster
Mike Jones he was so good at wrestling
yeah and he would just [__] your mind
and then you couldn't help it and he
would he would whisper what he was gonna
do to you and then pin you oh my God and
he would do it and it would stun you for
a second because you we all heard like
he's gonna whisper and then you're like
so you're waiting for the whisper and
then when you whisper you all you got to
do is pause a second he would just go
great
boom
there you go boom next thing either
because you're paying attention to that
the next thing you know you're on the
mat is like poop like he got me in the
headlight